foreign
[Music]
I don't know what you're expecting now
that you're back I'm respecting adequate
compensation
[Music]
I want you to go there the horse races
springboard mile there's nobody doing
nothing you can do whatever you want
not exactly the welcome I was expecting
my name's Tyson welcome to Tulsa
two grand a week you drive for me now
what crew runs this neighborhood no crew
up in here we're in the middle of
nowhere
what would it be I assume you don't have
chiante you assume correctly
I wouldn't have pegged you if it's the
Boy Scout why not
this wasn't necessary
what is that place it's a dispensary
[Music]
are you taking a break
this is how it's going to work I'll
protect you from The Gangs what gangs
and the law this is legal you got to
know your risk
there was no risk until you came along
ever heard of black Nick Adams
motorcycle gangs
they're overplaying your hand when I
play my hair you won't see it coming
any flammable liquids or firearms
in the Box nah
nation is not going to be controllable
for much longer
you got a pretty good appetite for
someone who was just shot at I stopped
eating every time somebody tried to hurt
me I'd be a skeleton
I want to be upfront
they were in the market
nah there's no such a thing there's a
one-off
or one of many
too soon to tell
[Music]